the mega swim up from the murky depths
to chomp on theater screens everywhere
after a long voyage out of prehistory
here's a look at how the creature
feature came together how it ends and
why there might be a follow-up massive
spoilers ahead based on Steve Olsen's
1997 book Meg a novel of deep terror the
Meg has been 20 years in the making
splashing fruitlessly in development
hell of multiple studios at various
stages Yemma del toro yonder bonds and
the Eli Roth were attached to direct
before national treasures jon turteltaub
took the helm and steered the thriller
to fruition as an American Chinese
co-production even then it wasn't
exactly smooth sailing shifting ratings
concerns kept the vision for the project
in flux at the heart of the story is
Rescue Diver Jonas Taylor played by
Jason Statham who joins a group of
scientists including his ex-wife on a
mission to take down a deadly supposedly
extinct 75 foot long Megalodon shark a
Statham puts it it's a fun short movie
that's like the ultimate popcorn movie a
bit of fun that doesn't take itself too
seriously
naturally the Meg concludes of an
escalating series of confrontations
against the prehistoric beasts including
one in which the audience is briefly led
to believe the shark has been filled
with poison alas the wrong ocean
carnivore was killed and after a grenade
attack launched from a helicopter also
fails a full swallow Hero Jonas to save
a crowded Chinese beach bursting out of
his damaged submersible
he scratches the Beast to make it bleed
and attract other sharks who devour the
Meg finally killing it
more this particular Megalodon
definitely won't be coming back there is
hope for a franchise featuring the
movie's human characters likely based on
the original novels many follow-ups the
Meg secret weapon just might be the
chemistry between us leads Jason Statham
and Li Bingbing playing oceanographer
suyin Zhang are a likable pair whose
romance blossoms on the face of shark
Tara seeing their relationship continued
to bloom while staring down the more of
another deep sea terror could make for a
perfectly charming follow-up then
there's engineering genius Jack's heard
played by up-and-coming Australian
actress Ruby Rose the Meg is one of
roses biggest screen roles yet after a
street that includes appearances and
oranges the new black XXX the return of
xander cage and John wick chapter 2 just
before the release of the Meg Rose was
announced to be playing Batwoman in the
seed
use DC Universe with a potential for a
show of her very own on the horizon yeah
that was probably the most grueling
audition process with a star rising as
rapidly as Ruby Rose's the idea of Jax
returning in Amex sequel would likely be
very appealing but there isn't really
any precedence for studios producing
quality shark attack based sequels so
this is uncharted territory
the original jaws is an undisputed
masterpiece that changed the face of
summer blockbusters forever but taken
together jaws 2 Joss 3d and jaws the
revenge provide one of cinema history's
most striking examples of the law of
diminishing returns plus we're about to
get a sixth sharknado
so if the Meg gets a sequel that it's
all well received it would be a first
the reviews for the Meg are decidedly
mixed but early box-office projections
predicted kids surpass all financial
expectations so only time will tell if
another journey to the bottom of the sea
is in Jason Statham's future
[Music]